[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA RUE: A big
thing about art is
getting to share that joy of
what you do with other people.
I took this art studio class
at MIT, and on the first day
the teacher asked the
students, "Why are we here?",
and a lot of them had
really similar answers.
I was basically, I used
to do art in high school
and I want to continue
it here now at MIT,
but I didn't really
have the chance.
So, I wanted to make this
project where other MIT
students could do that same
thing, where they could really
do art and have other
people appreciate it,
and get involved and find
happiness out of that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JULIA RUE: The Borderline is
a project where we're really
trying to get the MIT
community involved with art
in a kind of informal way.
It was open to MIT students
to just paint a mural
that they want, and
have in a public space
so other people could really
enjoy it and interact with it.
JESSIE WANG: There's definitely
a lot of artists on campus
that contribute a
lot to the community
that I guess you just don't
really hear about because they
do it on their own.
When we were looking
for submissions
for this project we've
got so many from people
that we didn't even know
were doing art on campus.
EMMA DESOTO: I've never done
really anything visual before,
but I do have this background
in mechanical engineering
where I'm used to
building things and trying
to make things look good,
and work, and be very
thorough in all my details.
It was really cool
to be able to apply
that in a very different
way than I have before.
JULIA RUE: I've done
only one mural before,
but I look around all
the time and see things
as a blank canvas.
So the tunnels were an obvious
choice, to me at least.
It not only livens
up this place,
but it really makes
it a destination.
JESSIE WANG: When you
think about a mural,
you usually think about a two
dimensional flat piece of work,
so for this project we decided
to add an augmented reality
component to it.
We made an app where
if you take your phone
and you look at
the mural with it,
you'll see hidden animation
start playing across it.
So, it's no longer a
still piece of artwork,
it's an animated piece of work
that also exists on its own
as a 2D mural if you
don't have the app.
EMMA DESOTO: It was really cool
to be part of this project that
started from nothing and
made something very real,
and something very tangible, you
can go down there and see it.
JESSIE WANG: This
kind of kick-started
having more student art
that's large on campus,
and it would be great if this
project itself could continue,
if we could maybe use
more space in a tunnel,
or white wall over this
and use the same space.
Either way, I think
it's just really great.
I hear so many people
talking about how
they're so happy the tunnels
have something in them now.
JULIA RUE: All these people
come from such different
backgrounds, we have
freshmen who are in biology,
and we have seniors who
are mechanical engineers.
I think it just goes
to show that there's
a lot of cool things that MIT
people can do that they don't
really have a chance to
showcase besides engineering
and their classes and stuff.
So, this is like a
little outlet for them
to showcase the other
sides of themselves.